عمر قاسم يعمل كعامل توصيل على دراجته
الناريه واحد من مئات الالاف من الذين
وقعوا ضحيه تطبيق هاك بول تلك المنصه التي
نجحت في الاستيلاء على سته مليارات جنيه
من مدخرات المصريين منذ انشائها منذ اكثر
من سته شهور قبل ان يتم اغلاقها ليتحول
حلم الثروه الى كابوس وعنوان لاشهر عمليه
نصب الكتروني انا رجل بطالب بفلوسي تمام
ان فلوسي ترجع لي ان انا يعني راجل شغال
على الله في يوميتي ما تجسيش ان انا اقعد
اسدد في الفلوس دي كلها اللي انا خسرتها
دي اسماء التي تعمل في مجال الهندسه كانت
ضحيه اخرى فالمنصه اوهمت عملائها بانها
تمتلك ماكينات للتعدين الخاص بالعملات
الرقميه ونجحت فعلا في توفير ارباح لفتره
قصيره انا مبلغى
في ناس تانيه مليون ونص وكده فالمبالغ مش
سهله واحده وتلاتين الف برضو احنا مش
جايبينها بسهوله يعني مش لاقيينهم في
الارض فهي الفكره احنا عاوزين حقنا يجي
فلوسنا بقى ترجع يتقبض عليهم كلهم ده اهم
حاجه حقنا
نجحت في القبض على مجموعه من المتهمين
اغلب الاموال تم تحويلها للخارج بالعملات
الاجنبيه النيابه العامه امرت بفتح تحقيق
موسع في القضيه قد تحيل النيابه المتهمين
الى محكمه بتهمه الجنايات بتهمه توظيف
الاموال وقد تحط الى محكمه الجنح
بجنحه النصب على المجني عليه
وايضا التهمه الثالثه وهي سئه استخدام
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
متخصصون في مجال التقنيه اكدوا استحاله
تمكن الحكومه واجهزتها في منع هذا النوع
من التطبيقات والمنصات التي تنتشر بشكل
كبير ده لازم يتم من خلال المنصه بالاتفاق
مع المنصه فالدوله تقدر تمنع ولكن لما
تعرف التطبيق بيعمل ايه فالتطبيقات دي كل
يوم فالحاله الوحيد فيها هو الوعي بتاع
الشخص ما فيش حاجه اسمها هتكسب من الهواء
ولا فلوس مضاعفه من مجرد تعدين او من
عملات بحطها وارجع اخد من وراها مكسب اسمه
هاك بول سينضم الى قائمه عمليات النصب
الشهيره والتي تنجح اغلبها في الاستيلاء
على اموال المصريين الذين يخدعون باوهام
الثراء السريع احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره